those were our best attacks and they did
nothing we can't be
can't be look we aren't strong enough to
beat Robotnik on our own but there's
three of us your strength your smarts
and my speed together that's how we win
so we make our stand here on the field
of battle as a team this is it
This is Our Moment
time to fight
[Music]
bad time to say this but I don't truly
have a plan
Tales any ideas we have to find his weak
spot I suggest
what no no no traditionally yes the
Brian is the weakest spot stop I'm
saying crime
I know what his weak spot is it's me I'm
the groin
think about it I live rent free in this
210 so I go out there and rile them up
you'll focus on only you leaving himself
open to a flanking maneuver from me and
the fox Hedgehog you are a brave and
Noble Warrior go to your certain death
With Honor we're gonna have to work on
your pep talks pal
yeah let's go
[Music]
all right mustache you want me come and
get me you don't tell me about coming
and getting I am on The Cutting Edge I'm
coming and getting coffee
oh you're really heavy that's because I
have one million percent muscle faster
Fox
[Music]
what the heck happened here
you thinking what I'm thinking let's go
get our kid we need your truck
[Music]
so what's the plan here
you got to build a big robot house get
yourself a big robot why I'm going to
enslave humanity and force them to
service my machines first Green Hills
then the universe then the Multiverse
then who knows maybe I'll be enough
full disclosure
[Music]
hi lasers
foreign
[Music]
giving up already not so tough when
you're fighting someone 700 times your
size are ya
you can feed me
I'm all powerful all-knowing
I'll see you
your fancy robot
over here
[Music]
um
I didn't outsmart you I'm just a
distraction
I am also a hologram this loyal this is
how I roll
[Music]
foreign
I like the new look it works for you
what do you say we just let bygones be
by gods I did some things you did some
things there are good people on both
sides
way too intelligent means
can work these things
[Music]
foreign
oh it's like that
okay we're not friends
foreign
[Music]
wait you cannot touch him the Hedgehog
holds the power of the animal
I'm sorry it is no longer the Sonic you
once knew
foreign
[Music]
okay here's exactly the Sonic you once
knew
[Music]
bring it in bud
ah it's gonna be back in blue the golden
God thing was fun but blue has always
been more my color looks good on you has
anyone ever told you you've got serious
anger issues you mock me with your weak
jokes but you know nothing about me
Hedgehog well I know you akinas have a
habit of showing up uninvited and
ruining my life ruining your life
another bad joke I lost everything
because of you my tribe was on the verge
of its greatest Victory the last of the
owl Warriors had been located soon long
claude's Emerald Secrets would be ours
my father stopped me from joining the
fight he said my moment to honor our
tribe would come but it was not this
moment those were the last words he
spoke to me
I never saw him again
we both lost everything that day
goodbye
Sonic are you okay deceiver
no no it wasn't a trip
Dallas take the compass and get out of
here
[Music]
foreign
ers
tails
tails come on wake up
you chose helping the fox over pursuing
the compass of course he did new friends
same pathetic weakness